the president faces new questions about
his dealings with Attorney General Jeff
Sessions today in an interview you'll
see in our next hour we talked to House
Oversight Committee Chairman trey Gowdy
about a report in today's New York Times
it says the president asked the Attorney
General last year to reverse his
decision to recuse himself from the
Russia investigation we asked
congressman Gowdy if that request was
actually made would it constitute
obstruction of justice I don't think so
I think what the president is doing is
expressing frustration that attorney
general sessions should have shared
these reasons for recusal before he took
the job not afterward if I were the
president and I picked someone to be the
country's chief law enforcement officer
and they told me later oh by the way I'm
not going to be able to participate in
the most important case in the office I
would be frustrated too that's how I
read that is senator sessions why didn't
you tell me this before I picked you
there are lots of really good lawyers in
the country you could have picked
someone else major Garrett is at the
White House where the president is
responding to what Gowdy said right here
in studio 57 major good morning good
morning on Twitter the president quoted
congressman Gowdy verbatim and then
added and I wish I did a reference to
the president wishing he had appointed
someone else as Attorney General now the
president has implied this before but
this is quite clearly as blunt as he's
ever been publicly about his misgivings
about the sessions appointment now it's
worth pointing out the president could
at any time fire sessions but he has not
sessions could resign last year he
threatened to do so but was talked out
of it so the uneasy semi peace continues
the president angry and the Attorney
General continuing to operate though
under a cloud overall president Trump
has decided if he fires sessions he will
have a nearly impossible task in winning
confirmation for sessions replacement
moreover on immigration law enforcement
and other issues sessions has
aggressively carried out the president's
agenda the source of mr. Trump's
frustration is that sessions recusal the
President believes set in motion events
that have enlarged the Russia
investigation of course that leaves out
the reality that mr. Trump's firing of
FBI director James Comey
also led to the appointment of a special
counsel but the president fundamentally
believes his sessions had not recused
himself Muller might not have been
appointed and the Russia probe might be
over by now
the president also overlooked gaudi's
comment that the FBI didn't infiltrate
the Trump campaign undermining a key
recent talking point of the president's
major thank you